fox news alert now the war in
afghanistan is officially over as
jennifer just said the last american
warplanes carrying u.s troops have left
afghan airspace and the taliban
announcing it is officially in control
of the kabul airport the pentagon says
american citizens are still there and
the state department will work to get
the remaining americans out secretary of
state anthony blinken said to speak at
any moment on this breaking news we'll
take around our table first though
pete having served
this must be filled with a lot of
different emotions yeah it's almost
it's almost surreal to see that banner
at the
the bottom right there america ends war
in afghanistan
uh i will say this setting aside all the
criticisms i and many others have had
i am very glad that every one of our
boys at this point is off of that
airfield off of that kill zone off of
that x
so you can you can talk about what was
mismanaged you can talk about the future
and we're going to talk a lot about that
about the people left behind about the
people come about the legitimized terror
states that that's there but ultimately
i got to tip my hat all to the to the
pentagon using an element of surprise
moving earlier than
many people would would think they would
and getting all our boys back so it has
not been a
smooth process we've lost 13 american
lives almost uh two dozen additionally
wounded that will not be forgotten but
it's it's a good thing that we're not a
target of isis k or al-qaeda or haqqani
right now
greg gutfeld i agree with everything
pete just said so that's all from me no
i'm kidding no but i do agree i i you
know i think that
it's it's a relief to know that this is
over but we know that in some ways it's
not yeah i mean we also know that the
analysis will not be over if that was
over i'd be out of a job but the fact is
it's just weird when you hear like it is
a new afghanistan at the same day that
you hear that they executed a folk
singer so there's all these other
elements out there and then of course
you have these conflicting stories about
whether or not isis and taliban they
hate each other but then why did they
release all the isis people from prison
i don't understand that either the
demilitarization is that what the word
is for the equipment
um he mentioned a few of it but there's
like tons and tons you saw that graph
that came out yesterday in the times of
all the weapons i think
so but the real thing now is is account
who's going to be accountable for the
big botch because that's what this is
this was the big botch uh and and it was
it's actually oddly a blunder made up of
smaller blunders and i don't know if
it's all joe's fault but it sure feels
that way because he's the guy at the top
but we need to you know we need to find
out i mean like if did the taliban
actually offer control of the airport
and did we decline that that's a pretty
huge blunder uh and that was that's it's
it's pale by the other blunders but you
can go you can keep going through them
and through them and find them
i think that's it's an important thing
to look at because i think it's going to
be i don't think it's as rosy as it's
going to look for the next couple of
weeks or and certainly possibly beyond
geraldo you were there many times
and covered many war zones and not
covered many ends
well you know
i was not here on the five last week
so i i want to express how gut-wrenching
and heartbreaking those deaths were and
how that affects everything including my
analysis of uh even though it was an an
in an incident
it was more than that it was symbolic of
so much and
delving into the 13 who died and
the the two of them women and the navy
corpsmen from close to where i live in
in ohio and five of them latinos of the
13th
so proud of them loved them so much
so pained by uh by their death
this stunning
end of this war is something that is
really
shaking me to my core it is a an amazing
thing 20 years it's been a big part of
my life it's why i came uh to fox news
all of us have you know some personal
effect of this uh of this uh story and
this trauma we left with honor i have to
say
the services performed magnificently if
the taliban bodyguards had been better
if the line had held and that the 13 had
not been killed i think we would have
forgiven president biden already for the
mismanaged the bungled
evacuation at the beginning i'm
delighted that they they demilitarized
those aircraft which means they made
them inoperable unusable so we didn't
what we left behind was a lot of small
arms and stuff they already had in terms
of the threat to the homeland
i'm of the school that says we have over
the horizon capability to strike if we
see them
you know coagulating again i i think
isis is very low tech right now
but as a father who had a daughter in
paris in 2015 for the attack that killed
over 150 french people
it doesn't take a lot of technology to
cause a lot of harm so i i think sadly
that's in our future i think we have
that violence in our future we have to
guard against it god bless tsa and all
the rest of them
it's going to be a wild time i
personally am relieved that the war is
over katy general mackenzie said there's
a lot of heartbreak with this departure
and he was talking about those that were
left behind including some americans
like 250 they say 250 americans and
numbers are hard to get but also the
special immigrant visas the interpreters
and others who helped in the war
i was talking to a marine friend last
week who was talking about what's going
to happen when we left and he also
agrees that we need to leave afghanistan
but he said once the lights go off and
the cameras are not rolling it's going
to be medieval
beyond anything that people can see and
so
looking at the end of the war i flash
back to 911 and how we got here i was 13
years old and a lot of my friends went
and they served their country and i just
want to say thank you to them for
everything that they
have lost and sacrificed for our country
um
you know we knew it was going to happen
but it's
the reality of it is a lot to take in
and process but i am deeply grateful for
the americans who put it all on the line
including the 13 last week to keep us
safe and i hope that we can continue to
do that when we add our voices to that
and lift them up and their families
jennifer griffin has been at the
pentagon with us helping us think
through all these issues reporting just
incredibly well jennifer throughout this
entire
war
let's get your thoughts as this comes to
an end on august 30th
well dana i just came out of the
pentagon briefing where general
mackenzie announced that those last five
military planes had cleared afghan
airspace we learned that on the last
flight out was general donahue the head
of the 82nd airborne who was one of the
top military commanders on the ground
along with the ambassador
the state department dod leaving
hand in hand with the american flag on
that last flight out
heartbreaking
images in terms of what general
mackenzie had to admit which was that
they did not get every american out who
wanted to leave
he mentioned that this will move from a
military phase to a diplomatic phase and
that the department of state will work
tirelessly to get any american out who
wants to get out by working with those
partners on the ground
which include the qataris who will have
an embassy open the turks who have their
embassy and who will be in charge of in
control of the airport the turkish nato
allies will work with the taliban to get
that airport operational so that uh that
uh commercial flights can come back in
general mckenzie was very clear that the
military took a decision not to destroy
aspects of the airport operational
aspects of the airport
so that things like fire trucks and and
command and control so that the
civilian aircraft can begin coming in
because there's going to be a
humanitarian disaster otherwise general
mackenzie also made the point that the
taliban is going to have its hands full
because as he said there are 2 000
isis-k fighters isis fighters that the
taliban themselves led out of the the
prisons the two key prisons one at
bagram air base one at polisharky
2 000 hardened isis fighters that's
going to be a problem because there are
no americans there right now no american
forces there right now for them to
target
they're going to turn their weapons on
the taliban and so that is i think the
tonight i think i feel certainly the way
uh i hear geraldo and i hear katie and
the emotion in everyone's voices we all
feel it the military here in this
building they feel it uh this is
has been a long 20 years and the war is
over but uh the heartbreak continues
we're going to take it around some for
some questions jen i think pete has one
for you now jennifer yeah it's ptech
haraldo uh said that you know we left
with honor and there's no doubt that our
troops performed honorably there is
honor in every aspect of what our troops
have done over the last 20 years
there's a lot of people feel like the
way that we left in the last couple
weeks was not honorable that it was a
retreat that it was at the behest of the
taliban we just saw the press conference
from the department of defense we will
soon see a press conference from the
department of state
do you feel like this is the moment with
all our troops home that the finger
pointing begins because ultimately it
was not a process handled properly uh do
you do you get a sense that from dod and
state there's going to be an attempt to
rewrite the narrative of who's to blame
for what didn't go right
i think for the finger pointing to begin
this soon is a is a bit unseemly frankly
and that is not the impression that i
have from uh the people who've been
working tirelessly since august 14th
i've seen people here at the pentagon as
well as at the department of state many
of them will remain nameless over the
years but they worked and they were
heroic in their efforts and the fact
that they got 122 000 vulnerable afghans
and americans out of that country when
they had to they had to fight their way
back in basically the airport scenes
you'll remember them the 82nd airborne
secured that airport in 24 hours and
there were for the most part other than
that tragic suicide bombing at abbey
gate
it was an it was an unbelievable effort
you had military planes landing every 45
minutes lifting people off to state
safety is it heartbreaking for
the military commanders that they had to
leave anyone behind obviously i just
asked general mackenzie how he feels
after 20 years of war handing the
country that they had seized from the
taliban after 9 11 back to the very same
taliban i can't imagine that anybody in
this country any american citizen is
going to be unchanged by what we've just
been through not only from the last 20
years but for the last two weeks
katie has a question for you jen
jennifer thank you so much for all of
your reporting over the past two weeks
but also over the years to bring
americans and our audience the most
important information on this very
crucial topic
i think there's some questions about a
lot of americans thought this was
happening tomorrow it happened today
tomorrow is august 31st obviously
there's a time difference with
afghanistan but can you talk about what
the general said about that in the
briefing well katie i think it's a good
point and certainly they had up until
midnight on august 31st in afghanistan
to uh to leave that was the deadline
that would have been about 3 30 p.m
eastern time but as you know with the
military there's always operational
security
considerations and if you look at those
five rockets that were fired at the
airport last night the fact that they
stopped a massive vehicle with
explosives and had to carry out a drone
strike with against two suicide bombers
in that vehicle uh earlier in the day
there was a sense that time was of the
essence and i think it's no surprise
that those planes would have taken off
um
you know it was august 31st in
afghanistan it's it's eight and a half
hours ahead of us right now and so they
left on august 31st that was the
deadline uh they
left and they did not leave under fire
so and they got people out safely and i
think that was the that was the ultimate
goal of the mission jen here's greg just
uh you brought the drone strike what uh
do we have any more information on the
casualties that people killed
we really don't and um centcom is
investigating if you're talking about
there were two drone strikes obviously
one from friday and then one
on sunday and that drone strike that
took place in the kabul neighborhood
about two miles from the airport that
was in a very dense kabul neighborhood
so
i would be shocked if there were not
civilian casualties the military takes
that very seriously centcom is
investigating um from initial reports
we've heard that it was from the uh
secondary explosion explosions from the
explosives that were in that vehicle
those two suicide bombers were packing
those explosives in the vehicle we were
told earlier today and there may have
been civilian casualties and and that
obviously was not the goal but the
danger in terms of allowing that vehicle
to head towards the airport so
devastation would have been much greater
geraldo has one for you and then i've
got one as well general mckenzie
jen spoke of the pragmatic relationship
of necessity with a long-term enemy
having to deal with the with the taliban
i'm of the school that the enemy of my
enemy is my friend the taliban hates
isis
that makes the taliban in this
formulation my friend i want the taliban
to snitch on isis i want the taliban to
go after isis is that the feeling in the
building that that the taliban will be
an unusual partner i mean germany joined
us against russia japan joined us
against china
is there a feeling that the taliban will
join us against isis
it was an absolute marriage of necessity
in these last two weeks to have to deal
with the taliban to have to negotiate
with the taliban to have taliban
provides security at the perimeter of
the airport that is not a relationship
that i envision continuing i believe
that the way the u.s military sees it is
that uh i that the taliban and isis
will go at it now and the u.s will keep
an eye on things and make sure that
nobody
leaves the country and poses a threat to
the u.s homeland or other countries
but as long as they're engaged on the
ground in afghanistan i think from the
military perspective the u.s military
perspective that's a good thing you
heard general mckenzie say that the
taliban were both pragmatic and
business-like those were his words in
these last two weeks the taliban wanted
the u.s to leave general mckenzie met
with mulla baradar at the beginning
after
august 14th he met with him in doha
qatar and he told him that if any u.s
troops were killed if the taliban
struck against the u.s forces at the
airport that the u.s would respond
forcefully that message was received
loud and clear from the taliban and so
now this moves into a new phase the
department of state will use whatever
leverage it has left not necessarily
military leverage but leverage in terms
of the world community
and they will use that leverage to try
and get the any americans who are left
uh who want to leave out and also any
afghan allies who are threatened by the
taliban they will be working tirelessly
to do that
greg's got a comment here well one of
the things about the enemy of my enemy
is my friend is that that can work
in reverse ways if isis hates us then
why can't they join taliban that's the
problem with the enemy versus enemy
thing so we never serve and i know that
this might have already been answered
over the weekend but you know
were there any taliban killed in the
suicide bombing i don't know
the taliban say so yes they did it is
reasonable to assume yeah really it was
120 kill yeah that's a pretty big blast
i just haven't heard it that's all yeah
jen i did have a question about um
you know the interpreters and other
helpers um there have been some private
efforts uh going on to try to help them
get out a lot of them were turned away
sometimes paperwork issues whatever
might have been couldn't get to the
airport a lot of them from our reporting
what we're hearing is that they are
being targeted and hunted down where
does that go from here
well dana it's interesting in the last
two weeks it was not paperwork issues
that were the problem those restrictions
were dropped as soon as the taliban took
over and the u.s military went back in
to begin these evacuations
so those the paperwork was no longer an
issue the issue and we saw this in real
time the issue was getting those
vulnerable afghans those afghan allies
whether they were sivs or people who had
worked in in some form uh with the u.s
government or women's groups who who are
now going to be targeted by the taliban
the real issue was getting through
taliban checkpoints the taliban were
willing to let americans through and
they were willing to let green hard card
holders through that's what they told
the u.s military sometimes they would
turn a blind eye and let a group of
afghans through but they were being they
did not want educated afghans to be
leaving the country they need them to
build the country and so the real
problem for most of the sivs and and
others who wanted to get to the airport
was that those taliban checkpoints on
the periphery people would try
five six times we would be on the phone
with them and hearing how they would get
turned back at that checkpoint and it
was absolutely gut-wrenching so now we
move into a new phase perhaps there will
be a land bridge corridor uh
out of the country where convoys of some
of these vulnerable afghans will be
escorted by by
friendly countries who maybe are still
on the ground in afghanistan working
with the state department but those
efforts are continuing they're just
moving into a new phase got it
we want to go to trey yingst he's in
doha cutter but before we do just pete
let me ask you if you want to comment on
anything that was said yeah no jennifer
great
great understanding of the situation on
the ground you know as was mentioned in
the briefing they said a few hundred are
left behind you mentioned the enemy
we've talked about the enemy of my enemy
how does in a dynamic situation like
that when we know american citizens are
left behind we know siv holders are left
behind the taliban can spin it as we
need their skills but they now have
their names and their biometric data in
many cases which makes them targets what
leverage do we have to prevent in the in
the middle of a civil war which is
likely to be unleashed prevent these
american citizens or allies of our from
becoming hostages from becoming uh poker
chips in a game between two groups that
want that leverage
i think that's a real a very serious
danger pete and
any american citizen who is left behind
they are vulnerable to hostage-taking
we know of one hostage who is still
being held by the haqqani network
but the real the really the vulnerable
the most vulnerable people i think are
those who worked as translators and
worked in s or or
members of the a a the afghan national
army the special forces the people who
fought alongside the u.s military those
people left behind the taliban they're
going to be at the top of the list for
the taliban going to seek retribution i
find it hard to believe that the taliban
would want to go and seek out and kill
americans you're right they could be
hostage and bargaining chips but but the
the ones are that are most vulnerable
are afghans who worked with us and who
weren't able to get out jen thanks so
much you'll stand by trey yanks has been
in doha cutter for us and trey let's get
your thoughts on what you're hearing
hearing and seeing as
one book ends and another one begins
well look we heard centcom general frank
mckenzie breaking down the numbers 6 000
americans evacuated since the taliban
took over but you still have 250
according to the u.s state department on
the ground in afghanistan in this
question of leverage will be the
question on everyone's mind moving
forward the united states does not have
much leverage over the taliban in terms
of negotiating the safe passage not only
of these americans but those estimated
80 000 special immigrant visa holders
afghans who helped the united states
over the past 20 years to make their way
out of the country it's such a dire
situation on the ground we're seeing
reports out of countries like iran and
pakistan and tajikistan of afghans
fleeing on foot the united nations
estimating over the next few weeks half
a million afghans could flee the country
over land borders because they don't
have this critical air bridge anymore
and that leverage question is going to
remain about how the united states will
be able to use diplomacy we heard
general mackenzie basically say that
they will have to rely not only on
allies but that loose relationship with
the taliban saying we're going to
negotiate very hard and very
aggressively to get those afghans out
what those negotiations will look like
it's really anyone's guess
oh yeah go ahead
i think this is like a
a key point here it isn't about the
military this was not a successful
airlift i'm sorry it wasn't we 120 000.
this is the worst military operation
i've ever seen it had nothing to do with
the military it had to do with a
government that let them down we are the
greatest military uh uh
on earth and we are at the we have to
rely on the taliban just putting that
sentence together
makes you sad and i i i i know that we
have war dude i know we did oh i i know
that and by the way i'm very happy that
we're getting out of there but we cannot
forget
how awful this was and how it let down a
lot of people
there are a lot of veterans who are
looking at this and they're sick to
their stomach and i i think the idea of
saying how successful this is we're
polishing a turd